in october
there was a shocking report out
that teachers at a salinas am i
pronouncing that right i don't know
salinas california middle school
secretly recruited students into a
pro-lgbt club
that was disguised as a gender equality
club
without their parents knowing this was
not just
uh teachers you know hosting a club for
kids with you know kind of different
sexual desires or confusion or something
and saying you can show up if you want
this was teachers going in tracking
their students online
trying to figure out which students were
maybe interested in this stuff and then
inviting them and recruiting them it was
really creepy
it was grooming i think is what you
would call it well that's what the
parents are calling it so this was this
was presented by abigail schreier
um who wrote the book irreversible
damage about transgenderism for little
girls
these kids were
indoctrinating pupils into accepting
progressive views of sex and gender uh
coaching students into changing their
gender telling them to hide this
stuff from their parents now the parents
are going out they're calling this
grooming this is a good tactic i think
we need to be a little bit blunter
let's be plain to quote ionopressly
let's be clear to quote ilhan omar
i think we need to be a lot blunter
about these things
these are creepy perverts they should
not
teach our kids and
they need to be chased out of
polite society kind of like dr fauci
because we can pass laws
and we can we can pass new policy
directives and we can have executive
orders but personnel is policy right the
people that we have
executing on these things are going to
determine what kind of policy we have we
can pass some resolution out of the
senate saying that fauci can or cannot
do something
but who cares there was a ban on gain of
function research dr fauci clearly
didn't care all that much about that
there have been all sorts of there's a
there's a law against perjury dr fouchy
doesn't appear to have cared very much
about that personnel is policy and so i
think we got to be a lot blunter we got
to be a lot more willing to own the libs
sometimes and we need to throw these
people out
right now it's looking like we're going
to have a good opportunity to throw the
libs out of office
in 2022
some members of congress and who knows
maybe 2024 it depends on whether or not
they they change all the voting rules
again
or we've got the phi beta kappa variant
at that point moving into the 17th year
of the coronavirus and so
all of the ordinary rules of government
are going to be suspended again
but yeah maybe look let's say we can get
the president out who's going to replace
him i don't know
if all of these bureaucrats if the
fouchies are still there
if the administrators are still there
even if some of these teachers and some
of these superintendents are still there
then it's not really going to matter
the fact is
joe biden has had basically no
legislative achievements this year and
yet the government has been extremely
effective and extremely radical so it's
gonna we're gonna have to think outside
the box why is this a serpent innocent
as a dove
in order to change it back
i'm so glad that you liked that clip
i want you to be exposed to the entire
show and you can do that when you
subscribe ring that bell
you will get the notifications if you
don't get them here you can go to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
type in the michael knowles show never
miss an episode we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you